1 wave of panic grippes the country.
Bed bugs proliferate in every place of the day,
hospitals,
schools,
working homes,
nursing homes,
prisons,
trains or even movie theaters.
They make 1 ordeal live 1.000.000 of our infested fellow citizens.
They make them lose sleep,
cause paranoia and isolate them socially.
Bed bugs are a national public health problem.
But you didn't do anything.
In two thousand ten seven,
there were two hundred thousand infested places.
I alerted.
You laughed in my face,
you didn't do anything.
Indeux-mille-vingt-deux,
there were 1.1000000 infested sites.
You acted and lied with an interdepartmental plan without any binding
measures and 1 announced observatory that never saw the light of day.
Madam Prime Minister,
6 years later,
it is your inaction that is largely responsible for this explosive situation.
The longer you wait,
the more out of control this situation gets.
When will you finally ban chemicals?
When 90% of bugs have developed resistance.
When will you finally stop delivering citizens to
themselves and to the voracity of private enterprises,
we demand,
1 public service of disinsectization,
free,
efficient,
guaranteeing health and environment.
On this subject,
there should be no cleavage,
there should be a collective determination to act.
So,
Madam President,
why do you once again stay in the excess?
Why don't you say?
Why don't you say that a year and a half ago,
in Marchdeux-mille-vingt-deux,
the interdepartmental plan to combat bedbugs,
carried by the Ministries of Ecological Transition,
Housing and Health,
drew the government's attention to this
phenomenon and provided initial answers.
This plan is first of all awareness to better identify
infestations and to inform individuals and professionals concerned.
Ladies and gentlemen,
bed bugs have infested most of the world's major cities.
Studies show us that their production is
related to tourist travel and resistance to.
However,
we are determined to continue to act and amplify our action and 1
meeting with all the ministries concerned will be held in the next few days.